Миколі 24 роки і він - ВІЛ-позитивний.
У 2022-му він офіційно став на захист України у лавах ЗСУ.
Але наразився на несприйняття і стигматизацію керівництва свого батальйону.
Поки командир чекав якогось рішення, щоб мене кудись перевести,
щоб у нього не було такої людини в батальйоні,
він придумав одне: побачив десь на території таку гору піску і сказав:
"Значить, треба взяти лопату і перетягти пісок в інше місце".
Я його спитав: нащо це робити?
Він каже: мені не потрібно, щоб було чисто, мені потрібно, щоб ти "задовбався".
Ще з підліткового віку Микола мріяв захищати Україну.
Однак з вірусом імунодефіциту лікарі роками визнавали його непридатним для цього.
Лише коли почалося повномасштабне вторгнення РФ
і війську були необхідні добровольці,
Миколі вдалося потрапити до ЗСУ - приховавши свій стан.
Зрозумів, що треба йти в армію, бо зараз точно мене не зупинять.
Бо як мінімум не спитають.
У перші дні не було часу на роботу цих комісій, брали всіх.
Комісії просто писалися заднім числом,
і це було нормально, бо треба були люди.
Тому і не сказав, тому що дуже хотів.
Микола мав запас таблеток на півтора місяця для спеціальної терапії,
що пригнічує вірус в організмі.
Щойно потрапив на фронт під Краматорськ,
повідомив медиків про свій статус і неможливість бути донором крові для інших.
Втім, проблеми чекали попереду:
таблетки закінчувалися, дістати нові через волонтерів виходило не одразу,
а нерегулярна терапія спричинила погіршення стану здоров'я.
Разом з тим місця служби Миколи ставали дедалі небезпечнішими:
він брав участь у контрнаступі ЗСУ на Харківщині,
а згодом - у боях під Бахмутом.
На щастя, крім контузій, чоловік не мав тяжких поранень
і не потребував переливання крові.
Але найстрашнішим йому запам'ятався момент,
коли зізнався про свій статус перед побратимами.
Я почав хворіти постійно, тобто це вже заважало реально служити,
бо чи в мене температура, чи в мене соплі, чи ще щось,
і в принципі я просто тягарем був.
І я кажу, що в мене така проблема, ВІЛ+, але я п'ю терапію, все нормально.
Мені сказали "ага", і через день почалися проблеми.
Не сказав, обманув, треба на лікування,
треба подивитися, чи не заражаю я інших.
Перестали вітатися за руку деякі люди.
За словами Миколи, командир робив усе,
аби спонукати його піти з армії.
Такі випадки у ЗСУ, на жаль, не поодинокі,
каже голова пацієнтської організації "100% життя" Дмитро Шерембей.
Він сам відкрито живе з ВІЛ-статусом.
24 лютого 2022 року пішов обороняти Київщину,
теж не пройшовши військово- лікарської комісії.
У перші дні війни було не до ВЛК.
Саме завдяки цьому багато ВІЛ-інфікованих у армії,
яких Дмитро знає особисто,
змогли приховати свій статус, аби уникнути упереджень щодо себе.
Якщо ВІЛ-інфікований іде до ЗСУ, приховуючи свій статус, -
це його особиста відповідальність, каже Шерембей.
Він таким чином приховує свій статус,
не дає можливості ні медбрату, ні своєму командиру
розуміти причину його проблем.
І він не приймає терапію.
Чи готовий він сам взяти на себе забезпечення свого здоров'я для того,
щоб, наприклад, служити в Збройних Силах України?
На це питання важливо знайти відповідь,
тому що людина, яка хворіє, не приносить користь,
постійно на лікарняному, і ніхто не знає, що робити,
вона забирає місце у військовозобов'язаного, який може туди піти.
У Центрі громадського здоров'я стверджують:
людина, яка регулярно приймає антиретровірусну терапію,
не має супутніх хвороб при ВІЛ і не приховує свій статус,
може служити у війську з мінімальним ризиком для себе та інших.
Такі підходи діють за кордоном, щоправда, не в умовах війни.
Приміром, у Німеччині ВІЛ-позитивні громадяни з 2017 року
мають змогу служити у армії, якщо проходять ефективну терапію
і не мають ознак захворювання
за результатами комплексного медичного обстеження.
З серпня цього року міністерство оборони України
офіційно дало змогу мобілізувати українців з визнаним позитивним ВІЛ-статусом
усіх стадій інфікування, якщо хвороба проходить безсимптомно.
Чи може ВІЛ-інфікований проходити військову службу, визначає військово-лікарська комісія.
Людина, яка живе з ВІЛ, приймаючи антиретровірусні препарати за станом здоров'я,
нічим не відрізняється від людини без ВІЛ і може бути військовослужбовцем.
Інша ситуація, коли людина з ВІЛ знає про свій статус,
але не приймає препарати,
тоді оці певні навантаження, переохолодження і перебування в зоні воєнних дій,
якщо це військовослужбовець, може призвести до погіршення стану здоров'я.
Це можливість прояву туберкульозу, туберкульозної інфекції.
З юридичної точки зору, кажуть правники, виникають питання до того,
що під час проходження служби в ЗСУ законодавством не передбачене
обов'язкове тестування бійців на ВІЛ та профілактика захворювання загалом.
Також спірним, на думку адвоката Тараса Яреська,
є те, що військово-лікарська комісія не вказує у своєму висновку,
на яких саме посадах та у яких формуваннях може служити людина з ВІЛ,
враховуючи стан її здоров'я.
ВЛК може лише рекомендувати призначення у ті чи інші види військ,
за винятком ССО, десантно-штурмових військ та морської піхоти.
Утім, це не виключає ймовірності, що ВІЛ-інфікований
все одно може опинитися на передовій.
Як у нас міністр оборони колишній говорив,
що, звичайно, обмежена придатність означає, що вони будуть служити тільки в тій категорії військ,
де їх можна долучити за станом їхнього здоров'я,
щоб вони не шкодили іншим і так далі. Але ж це слова!
Військовослужбовець з ВІЛ може бути в підрозділі забезпечення,
але все одно на полі бою може бути!
Підрозділ забезпечення це дуже широке поняття.
Це створює додаткові ризики як для самого ВІЛ-інфікованого,
так і для його побратимів на фронті, підтверджує Дмитро Шерембей.
За його словами, у міністерстві оборони вже визнають
недоліки процесу мобілізації українців з ВІЛ
і над доопрацюванням необхідних документів
працюють спільно з організацією "100% життя" та з іншими експертами галузі.
Однак сам факт надання права громадянам з ВІЛ захищати Батьківщину Шерембей вважає позитивом.
Ми маємо розуміти, в які війська ми їх мобілізуємо,
маємо розуміти, який медичний сервіс для них буде доступним.
Ми маємо розуміти ступінь знищення їхнього імунітету і стан їхнього здоров'я.
У цьому просто треба навести порядок!
У людей, у яких є статус, має з'явитися право самостійно прийняти рішення, що він хоче служити.
У людей, які мобілізують їх, має бути можливість
організувати для них умови, в яких вони це право реалізують!
Микола, який після вторгнення РФ добровільно пішов у ЗСУ,
приховавши свій ВІЛ-статус, наразі комісований:
за станом здоров'я його звільнили з війська.
Чоловік шкодує, що не зізнався командирові та побратимам
про свій статус одразу на початку служби.
Він вважає, що тоді вдалося б уникнути багатьох непорозумінь у батальйоні.
Не підходять люди, якщо знають, на метр, бо мало там що.
У підрозділах це дуже погано. Бо має бути якесь злагодження, не дай Бог що,
щоб я розумів, що мене витягнуть чи я когось витягну.
А коли є такі конфлікти, це впливає на роботу.
Після додаткової терапії вже навесні Микола планує
пройти військово-лікарську комісію і відкрито стати до лав захисників як ВІЛ-інфікований.
Його мрія - бути частиною перемоги України:
і над армією РФ, і над дискримінацією таких, як він, у війську.